data science as a technology field has
grown vastly over the last five years it
has become one of the most preferred job
roles for professionals and young
students
hello everyone welcome to this video by
simplyloan today we will learn about the
top 10 highest paying data science
careers
in this video we will explore the
different data science careers the
responsibilities and the skills that you
need to possess
finally we look at the salary structure
of these job roles
the first data science career we have is
that of a data analyst
data analysts are individuals who
collect the data from various data
sources and filter it to get value out
of it
data analysts use different tools to
analyze and visualize the data that
helps in decision making
they often work with data stored in
relational databases
they explored the data to find unseen
trends and transform business data into
valuable insights
data analysts perform data handling data
modeling as well as data reporting
now
let's look at the skills possessed by
data analysts
they should have hands-on knowledge of
sql
so they should know how to retrieve and
manipulate data using microsoft sql
server mysql and nosql databases such as
mongodb and cassandra
the need to know python and r
programming languages
this would be good at data visualization
like excel and tableau to name a few
talking about the salary structure of a
data analyst
according to glassdoor the average
salary of a data analyst in the united
states is around 62
453 dollars while in india it is around
5 lakh 6 000 rupees per annum
the second data science career we have
is of a business analyst
business analyst is a professional who
uses data analytics and modern tools and
technologies to gather requirements
assess processes and deliver data-driven
solutions
they are responsible for bridging the
gap between the it team and the business
team in an organization
they understand the business goals and
collect business requirements from
clients and stakeholders
business analysts allocate the right
resources and improve existing business
operations they also give feedback to
the layout of a software application as
to what all features need to be added
and how to implement the newly designed
features that a business needs
moving on to the skills
business analyst possess both technical
as well as non-technical skills which
are also called as soft skills
this would have good knowledge of sql
and programming languages such as python
business analysts need data
visualization and excel skills to create
and visualize reports
apart from that they should also possess
critical thinking and presentation
skills
coming to the salary structure of a
business analyst
according to glassdoor the average
salary of a business analyst in the
united states is 68
346 dollars
while in india a business analyst earns
6 lakh rupees per annum
up next we have the career of a business
intelligence analyst
a business intelligence analyst is
responsible for handling vast volumes of
data by querying relational databases
and then producing reports and
dashboards to identify trends and
generate actionable business insights
the develop and manage bi solutions and
collaborate with business users and
analyze business processes and
requirements
business intelligence analyst performs
data profiling to identify and
understand anomalies
business intelligence analysts can
identify trends that can help other
departments managers and executives to
make business decisions and improve
processes in an organization
let's have a look at the key skills of a
business intelligence analyst
you should have good hands-on experience
with relational database management
systems such as microsoft sql server
mysql oracle db as well as knowledge of
etl such as informatica
they should be able to create data
visualizations and reports using power
bi click view and tableau
coming to the salary
as per glass door a business
intelligence analyst in the united
states earns nearly 76 402 dollars in
india you can earn an average salary of
6 lakhs 50 000 rupees per annum
the fourth data science career we have
listed is for a statistician role
a statistician is a professional who
applies statistical methods to real
world problems
they apply statistical theories and
methods to collect analyze and interpret
quantitative data
they decide what data they need design
experiments analyze and interpret data
and report conclusions
according to the bureau of labor
statistics which groups statisticians
with mathematicians
the job outlook for the industry is
positive
the overall employment for
mathematicians and statisticians is
expected to grow 30
from 2018 to 2028 which is nearly five
times as fast as growth for all
occupations
now talking about their skills
a statistician should be well versed
with tools such as r and sas
they should be able to analyze data
using excel spss and starter
talking about the salary
a statistician earns nearly 76 884
dollars in the united states while in
india you can earn close to 6 lakh
rupees per annum
now
let's move on
and talk about database administrator
database administrators or dba are
professionals responsible for the
performance integrity and security of
databases
they are often involved in planning
developing and troubleshooting of
databases they test and modify databases
to ensure that they operate reliably
a database administrator provides
guidance and support to application
developers and helps with schema design
code review and maintenance of databases
they create backup and recovery plans
and procedures based on industry best
practices
some of the major skills of a database
administrator are
they need to be good with relational and
no sequel databases like mysql oracle db
and mongodb
they should be able to query information
from hadoop related databases such as
scoop hbase as well as ibm db2
moving on to their salary structure
a database administrator in the united
states earns an average salary of
seventy eight thousand seven hundred and
seventy nine dollars per annum
while in india you can earn around six
lakh eighty six thousand rupees per
annum
now before moving ahead
i would like to tell you that if you
have enjoyed watching this video so far
then please subscribe to simply learn
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
now at number six
we have the data science career of a big
data engineer
big data has revolutionized every
business sector over the last decade
a big data engineer creates and manages
business data infrastructure and tools
they collect store process and analyze
companies data
they are responsible to develop design
maintain and test the big data
architecture in an organization
they handle the etl process and discover
ways for data acquisitions
they process unstructured data into a
form suitable for analysis
now let's look at the skills of a big
data engineer
a big data engineer should have
knowledge of hadoop and the tools in its
framework such as hive and pig
they need to have data warehousing
skills along with mongodb and talent
now talking about the salary of a big
data engineer
as per glassdoor a big data engineer in
the united states earns nearly hundred
and three thousand dollars in india you
can earn nearly eight lakh rupees per
annum
now at number seven we have a data
consultant career
data consultants use data sets and
models to draw meaningful insights and
solve problems
they advise organizations about big data
procurement a data strategy and which
technologies best fit the needs of the
organization
data consultants help in making
strategic data-driven decisions by using
machine learning models
they examine data processes and
technologies to evaluate the current
state and critical problems
some of the skills possessed by data
consultants are sql programming
languages such as python as well as
hadoop
this would be good with power bi tableau
machine learning and should be good at
problem solving
talking about the salary of a data
consultant
as per glass door the salary of a data
consultant is 76 402 dollars in the
united states while in india it's around
6 lakh 50 000 rupees per annum
moving ahead
now we have another interesting data
science career that is
a data modeler
a data modeler understands and
translates business needs into data
models supporting long term solutions
they work with the development team to
implement data strategies build data
flows and develop conceptual data models
a data modeler creates logical and
physical data models using best
practices to ensure high data quality
and reduced redundancy
they optimize and update logical and
physical data models to support new and
existing projects
data modelers identify areas where data
can be used to improve business
activities defining business users
requirements let's talk about the skills
of a data modeler
so a data modeler should be good at
writing sql queries and they should be
able to write programming logic using
java python or r
they need to know machine learning and
tools such as power designer
now let's look at their salary
according to pay scale a data modeler
earns an average salary of 81 227
dollars in the united states while in
india you can earn nearly 10 lakh 66 000
rupees per annum
moving ahead
at number 9 we have the job role of a
machine learning engineer
the job of a machine learning engineer
is to create intelligent machines
they create programs that will enable
machines to take actions without human
involvement
a self-driving car is an example of a
system a machine learning engineer would
work on
the develop machine learning models
using structured and unstructured data
and design self-running software to
automate predictive models
machine learning engineers research
experiment and implement suitable
machine learning algorithms and tools
the frequently used supervised and
unsupervised machine learning models to
make decisions
now a machine learning engineer should
be good with statistics probability and
linear algebra
they should have hands-on experience
with programming languages such as
python and r having knowledge of machine
learning algorithms is important for
this role
finally they need to have data
visualization skills as well
now let's look at the salaries of a
machine learning engineer
so as per glassdoor a machine learning
engineer in the united states earns
around 114 000 dollars and in india you
can earn an average salary of 7 lakh 65
000 rupees per annum
finally we have the most exciting data
science career which is of a data
scientist
a data scientist tool combines three
other job roles
that are computer science statistics and
mathematics data scientists analyze
process and model data
they interpret the results to create
actionable plans for companies and other
organizations
they understand the challenges in
businesses and use modern tools and
techniques to analyze visualize and
build prediction models to solve
business problems
they employ sophisticated analytical and
statistical methods to prepare data for
use in predictive and prescriptive
modeling
data scientists discover new algorithms
to solve problems and build programs to
automate repetitive
work now a data scientist should be good
at a lot of skills
they need to know sql python and r
apart from that data scientists should
be good with machine learning business
intelligence and problem solving
now let's talk about the salary of a
data scientist
according to glassdoor
a data scientist in the united states
earns an average salary of 113 000
dollars per annum
in india you can earn around 9 lakh 16
000 rupees per annum
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career in data
science and land you a data science job
role
so let me take you to the simply learn
website
and let me search for simplylearn.com
here under what you want to learn
i'll search for
data science
okay so simplylearn provides a lot of
courses
related to data science so let me open
the first two
courses
so the first course is a masters program
to become a data scientist now this
course is in collaboration with ibm
if you see on the right
we have all the courses that will be
covered as part of this program so the
first course is on our programming
you will learn data science with python
the third course is on machine learning
then you will also be trained on tableau
you will learn about big data hadoop and
spark
and
you'll also get to work on some capstone
projects
if i scroll down
here you can see some of the benefits of
this course you also get simply learn
jobassist
if i scroll further
this is the certificate that you would
receive after completing the course
and here you can see some of the tools
that will be covered you will learn
about
flume
numpy this pandas
scipy spark you'll learn about ibm
watson
hive pig there's hdfs python r scala and
there are other tools as well
you can see the scores advisor
if i scroll down here you can see the
entire learning path
and there are a few electives as well
that you can choose
if you enroll for this course so we have
ibm watson for chatbots
then there's machine learning with r
there's sql training
and here is the master's program
certificate that you would receive
so please go ahead and enroll to this
course if you want to start your career
as a data scientist
now the next course is the post graduate
program in data science
this is in partnership with purdue
university and in collaboration with ibm
if i scroll down
here you can see the key features of
this course so you would get purdue post
graduate program certification
podu alumni association membership then
enrollment to simply lens job assist
there's 300 plus hours of blended
learning 25 plus hands-on projects on
integrated labs
caption projects in three domains and
there are other features as well
now
here is the certificate that you would
receive after finishing the course
and you would also
get certificates from ibm
now you also have the advantage
to enroll in simply lens job assist that
is you would get im jobs pro membership
for six months
there is resume assistance and career
monitoring interview preparations
and below you can see the program
details
so first you would learn
our programming data science with r
python for data science
then there's machine learning natural
language processing
we have a few electives as well
if i scroll further
here you can see the skills that will be
covered so you would learn about
exploratory data analysis descriptive
statistics influential statistics this
natural language processing supervised
and unsupervised learning and symbol
learning and lots more
and here you can see the tools that will
be covered
now coming to
the important part you can see you will
get to work on some industry based
projects so first is the
fair prediction for uber
then there is test bench time reduction
for mercedes bench
then you have another project from
amazon there's one more from
demand forecasting for walmart and from
comcast as well
so these are our course advisors for the
course
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you want to grow your career
in the field of data science
and that brings us to the end of this
video on the 10 highest paying data
science careers
we hope you have found this informative
and helpful if you enjoyed this video
please like and share it and don't
forget to subscribe to simply learn
channel
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here